pour bain de minuit Jean Rousseau a pu
filmer les 4000 m² casinalaya vient de
s'offrir rue de la Verrerie
c'est par chercher un local et à chaque
fois qu'on me proposait un endroit je
trouvais tu es trop luxueux pour moi
c'est des hôtels particuliers ou des
immeubles trop somptueux
et quand j'ai visité ici c'était
un espèce de
mélange qu'on dit vu les La Verrière
dans woluweetha les murs
alors j'ai foncé j'ai dit ça ça me plaît
l'endroit après petit à petit
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait des choses
intéressantes
[Musique]
les cartes je crois parce qu'il faisait
des expéditions
alors c'est j'ai découvert qu'il y avait
des cartes une fraise et ça je trouve
très très beau parce que je peux voyager
sur place là maintenant je vais
apprendre la carte de France
l'Angleterre
la Méditerranée et tout
on voit là c'est le nouveau local qui
est rue de la Verrerie et qui va
remplacer celui de la rue du Parc Royal
c'était quoi avant
c'est des anciens le code BHV
et il doit être des ateliers ou
d'entreposer beaucoup de choses dedans
ça fait 4 surfaces à peu près
un peu plus 400
les grandes verrière ça va servir pour
le défilé
c'est très très grande surface mais
ça va être occupé tout tout par la
connexion 88 c'était très inspiré par le
Petit
Hôtel du Nord les visiteurs du soir
c'est quand même c'est quand même
bizarre ça d'aller rechercher un laitier
aujourd'hui ça signifie beaucoup pour
toi moi c'est énorme pour moi oui parce
que quand je suis arrivé que tu
connaissais pas du tout
arithini les films jamais vu et
j'habitais dans le 16e et la première
fois que j'ai vu dans une cinémathèque
les enfants de paradis
j'ai trouvé que c'était quelque chose
qui m'a bouleversé de sa façon de jouer
la voix et tout après c'était ainsi
qu'il y avait Hôtel du Nord et d'un coup
vraiment j'ai flashé là-dessus je me
suis dit c'est pour moi elle
représentait la France La Parisienne
telle que tu l'as rêvait depuis c'est
très difficile plus parisien qu'elle
parce que c'était un langage très simple
et en même temps
très élégant et avait une grandeur comme
ça illégance
et après il s'est trouvé que j'ai
rencontré tout de suite après c'était
vraiment une chance et
je l'ai vu plusieurs fois chaque fois
que je la voyais j'apprenais quelque
chose vraiment de sa façon son style
comment il s'habiller parce qu'elle
était toujours avec des trucs répétés
la première fois que c'est dans l'Hôtel
du Nord où je l'ai visité et j'ai trouvé
cette attitude la silhouette
et jusqu'à maintenant chaque fois que je
dans chaque collection il y a une pensée
comme ça qui vient ou une phrase ou
mettez un poster dans les petites dans
ton
et je trouve que pour moi
c'est une des plus la femme la plus
moderne et la plus libre comme ça et
j'aime bien cette façon cette liberté à
quand tu étais petit à Tunis et
d'arletti quand tu rêvais tu la voyais
dans les journaux dans les cinémas et
tout ça c'était à l'école des Beaux-Arts
et c'était facile par la mode parce que
je voyais dans les revues balancer AGA
et des vêtements de Dior et j'étais
atterré ce but c'est toujours demandé
comment ils sont faites ces robes
intérieures comment ça tient tout ça
c'est vrai que dans un cinéma puis que
tu lui racontais les films à tes copains
à l'école en échange de créanciers
mon grand-père était agent de police il
m'a amené au cinéma qui s'appelait ciné
soir et là ça donne tous les films
égyptiens et il y avait Oum kalthumé
avec tous les films égyptiens
et j'arrivais le déposer c'était son
copain et je dis assis sur à l'arrière
sur un extrapontin je voyais le film
quatre fois et j'apprenais par cœur
parce que des quatre fois plus pendant
le mois c'est quatre fois par semaine et
après quand je retourne à l'école
c'était nul en tout moment et la seule
chose qui se faisait bien c'est raconté
les filles donc voilà la situation
en échange des crayons de couleurs c'est
beau comme histoire et si je leur
faisais les chansons c'est plus cher le
crayon de couleur
mais tu as une enfance très heureuse
quand même non c'est une grande maison
qui m'a sauvé je pense
quand tu as eu 12 ans tu es en vacances
dans l'endroit qui s'appelait-iliana
agriculteur on t'a offert une vache qui
était toute malade et tout en occupé
c'est beau aussi moi j'aime bien
parce qu'il était agriculteur il avait
beaucoup de chevaux des vaches des
animaux et quand on est petit il nous
offrait chacun une basse ou en général
et moi il m'avait il me dit bon il y a
le marché le jeudi mais tu viens avec
moi et mon père il me dit parce qu'il
parlait pas à son père devant moi mais
moi je voulais parler pas du tout parce
qu'il y avait un tel respect pour son
père que il y avait des mains derrière
croisé il avait même pas la tête et il
me dit avant de sortir surtout on
choisit une vache normande il y a
Monsieur sa tête qui était un colon
Tunisie qui était son copain aussi il a
des vaches normandes ils sont grandes
choisissent ça parce qu'il donne
beaucoup de lait et quand j'étais dans
ce marché je voyais un avec les petites
vaches maigres petits avec les cordes au
cou mais vraiment une ficelle et quand
je dis alors il me tiré et avec la tête
qui me secouait comme ça discrètement
devant son père pourquoi je regardais
les grosses vaches
des dossiers Châtel et moi je voyais
devant je sortais Nord c'est pas
possible il faisait peur et je voyais
ces petites vaches du sel si je veux
pas cher du tout et cette vache alors
j'ai tenu bon et il voulait pas me
l'acheter même mon grand-père
j'étais content parce que j'arrivais à
la maîtriser il a tenu par la corde elle
a une petite corne cassée minuscule moi
j'ai trouvé cette vache était bien elle
avait un bon regard très doux et cette
vache elle a été géniale même quand elle
revenait avec le troupeau elle tapait
avec ses cordes sur la porte de la
maison pour te dire qu'elle était là
pour gagner et elle rentrait alors moi
je la brosse tout comme un chien après
mais dis-moi
[Musique]
je suis tombé dans des conditions
différentes je t'ai toujours chez des
familles ou vraiment
c'était des Français fantastiques mais
une situation depuis que tu es en France
tu as eu à souffrir quand même un
certain sans parler de racisme
du tout ça t'inquiète on Le Pen fait 14
% élections
non non
quand tu arrives en France tu tu as vécu
chez une comtesse qui s'appelait la
comtesse de Béziers tu t'occupes un peu
des enfants c'est des drôles comme
histoire ça aussi c'est à dire que tu
faisais un peu de Baby encore maintenant
tu t'occupais des enfants puis en même
temps tu faisais des robes pour les
professionnels c'était fantastique pour
moi parce que c'est pour ça cette
période-là j'étais très heureux parce
que je vivais avec dans cette famille et
j'avais même un papier comme quoi qui
j'étais leur protéger et tout
m'arrêter la police dans la rue alors je
sortais mon papier c'est vite j'étais
relâché pas du tout j'avais pas de
problème et j'étais vous habiter chez
elle et je crois que c'est une période
fantastique pour moi je suis amusée avec
les enfants
j'allais au bois me promener avec eux et
en contact avec la France quoi ah oui
oui alors après tu rencontres des gens
comme Louise de Villemorin ou Simone
zerfus qui t'ont permis de d'aller plus
loin dans le métier parce que chaque
fois j'ai rencontré des gens
fantastiques et chez les vertus j'ai
rencontré beaucoup d'artistes César j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de gens et ça c'est
pour moi c'est
peut-être ça va
apporter quelque chose tu as décidé à
monter la rue de belle chasse en tous
les cas oui c'est ça qui t'a décidé
comment tu as connu Grace Jones
stinaturne away enfin toutes tes
clientes les plus célèbres sont venu te
voir comme ça
et pourquoi quelqu'un les avait envoyé
non quand ils ont vu les vêtements
quelque chose comme ça ils sont
même pas mon nom elle a raconté et
elle est venue à Paris et elle a
téléphoné elle dit qu'elle voulait me
rencontrer et là c'était fantastique je
trouve que qu'est-ce que tu penses que
dans les livres d'histoire on dira toi
tu as apporté quoi la mode
[Musique]
plusieurs choses c'est un mélange comme
ça de personnes qui apportent quelque
chose je pourrais t'arrêter du jour au
lendemain
je veux pas être financier je veux pas
de gens derrière moi parce que le jour
où je sais que je c'est pour ça que j'ai
décidé reculer le défilé je dis tant pis
même si les acheteurs ne reviennent pas
les journalistes s'il y a quatre
journalistes françaises qui viennent
c'est suffisant c'est pas la peine que
ça devient une obsession pour la
consommation à la vente si ça va plus
non je fais autre chose il y a beaucoup
de choses qui m'intéressent tu regardes
encore des vogues et des l des années 50
comme tu faisais à Tunis
avant je regardais beaucoup beaucoup sur
tous les photos de carte d'identité ah
bon parce que mon grand-père était agent
de police au service du card d'identité
et j'ai ramassé tous les photos qui
jetaient ce qui avait trois photos à me
donner il y a une dans le dossier
agrafer et une sur le passeport
et je me rappelais parce que je l'ai à
côté de cette jeune femme qui faisait le
et
il y avait une au cas où il y a un
accident sur une photo en remplacé
dans un panier moi je prenais le panier
j'ai demandé je mettais dans un sac et
je rentrais et ça c'était mon jeu
préféré
alors j'ai sélectionné les blancs les
brunes et après je le regarde dans les
plus beaux jeunes de côté et je vérifie
tous les semaines si j'ai changé d'avis
et après c'était atroce pour moi parce
que moi dans la rue j'ai rencontré les
gens j'avais l'impression que je
connaissais je pensais vers eux et
c'était les photos je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais toute une histoire
pourquoi il est pas là
et il est pas là parce qu'il
se repose ce soir ah bon et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu